what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with Predator versus Wolverine
and as always we will have a playlist
Link at the end of this video so you can
get caught up but in the last video we
basically had the Predator who had
consistently faced off against Wolverine
and even more than one Predator fighting
wolin when he had bone claws but things
are different now because this next time
that the Predator catches up to
Wolverine he's in the midst of the
adamantium bonding process with Weapon X
that's right ladies and gentlemen the
moment you've all been waiting for so
here's the thing right as soon as the
Predator Gets up to Wolverine and starts
to basically examine him he realizes
that there's metal attached to his bones
and the cool thing about this right for
those of you guys who aren't really
familiar with their Predator Mythos
these guys are Trophy Hunters right the
ultimate Hunter the idea is that whether
by way of a right of passage or just as
kind of a general enjoyment of their
race overall in multiple capacities they
travel across all of of creation and
they track down and hunt various
creatures that they find as a test of
themselves right constantly improving
themselves the kicker about all this is
that while wolverin is technically
unconscious the Predator's actions wake
wolver rain up and then it immediately
attacks him right like Wolverine
immediately attacks the predator and the
Predator responds in the only way that
it can right it takes the acid and pours
it in Wolverine's mouth and Wolverine is
basically taken out because what had
happened here is a predator had looked
at Wolverine and realized he is the
perfect trophy right a being who is
effectively indestructible now the
question has to be asked what does a
predator understand about adamantium
because adamantium was created on Earth
it doesn't exist anywhere else in space
or outside of Earth so there's not
really a way that the Predator could
know outside of using its technology to
examine adamantium recognize its Atomic
makeup and then realize how
indestructible it is which is probably
exactly what it did right I mean of
being that capable that travel
all throughout space the way that it
does it probably has more than a passing
knowledge of like chemistry and
biochemistry and Sciences and all that
kind of stuff and so with Wolverine
taken out it basically goes to its ship
now here's a cool thing and I'm curious
to see whether or not you guys spot this
so if you look on the wall of this
Predator there is a particular skull
that is here it's up at the top and it's
a rainc COR skull in effect Marvel
Comics like the Marvel un ierse and Star
Wars share the same universe which kind
of makes sense right long ago in a
galaxy far far away so it makes perfect
sense that like because Marvel's writing
Star Wars and because now you have like
the regular superheroes who have always
kind of been here that they're all in
the same universe which begs the
question when are we going to see a Star
Wars and Marvel Superhero crossover only
a matter of time but I figured I'd kind
of poke out or at least point out that
little Easter egg now following that
right Wolverine's healing Factor being
what it is it always basically helps him
to regenerate now this is one of the
caveats about this it's an inconsistent
aspect of Wolverine's healing Factor
right ever since Civil War he's just
been able to effectively heal from like
nothing but adamantium right ever since
that story line when he did it it's kind
of been a normal part of his character
right prior to that if he was
incinerated down to the skeleton he was
basically done and gone we know that
because of days of future past but one
of the things to know here is that
breaking into a weapon x facility is no
small thing right it's going to go
notice right because Weapon X is a joint
venture between Canada's Department H
and the United States CIA Department h
of course being Canada's kind of like
superhero research program but like it's
a multi-g government operation it's
ridiculously clandestin and super off
the books but like people are going to
notice and that's exactly what happens
as soon as this Predator starts to
activate its ship suddenly he's fired on
by like a couple of f-16s and then of
course it manages to take one of those
f-16s out but when the question is asked
of Schwarz right one of the pilots
where's this thing going she's like it's
just going up right it's literally going
to the Moon that's when she's told to
fire everything they have but of course
as we know these Predator ships right
these things are shielded they're not
easily destroyed so there's like nothing
that an F-16 is going to be able to do
here this thing just takes off and
ultimately like the F-16 has to pull
back at 70,000 ft and that's when you
come across Berserker rage Wolverine now
I know some people have heard of
Berserker rage Wolverine there was no
better depiction of this than during
Jeff Lam's Old Man Logan run with Andrea
sorantino right like let myself become
Madness death right like that kind of
thing like it's just one of the coolest
moments one of the coolest depictions
ever but Berserker rage wolver rain is
when wolver rain just loses any sense of
like sentience right like just human
intelligence and just devolves into an
animalistic State it's his most
dangerous form and in fact whenever this
happens around the X-Men un unless
there's some kind of telepath there
these guys just run for their life they
will rarely ever decide to try to fight
and calm down a Berserker rage wol rain
because he'll kill them all right so
again like it's a very very dangerous
version of him but instead of just like
attacking the Predator he basically
starts clawing his way out of the ship
right again kind of an animalistic State
not really thinking because if he was he
would have been like okay so it's time
for this Predator to die he would have
just killed this thing and then just
called it a day then like jumped out of
the ship right but whatever it is he
ends up jumping out and crash landing
down on Earth where he's recovered by
Professor Thorton and the rest of weapon
x here's the kicker about all this and
it's one of the things that I love about
this right we don't really know at least
I don't really know the ins and outs of
how the Predator helmets work I'm sure
it's been explored over the course of
the Predator expanded universe but for
its intense and purposes here Professor
thoron ends up reverse engineering the
capabilities of the Wolf Wolverine
helmet and that's how they developed the
helmet that's attached to Wolverine's
head during Weapon X the one they used
to brainwash it so like it's a really
cool bit of historical adjustment here
by Benjamin Percy because what we never
really knew when it came to this story
is if this story kind of took place in
an alternate reality or something along
those lines right seemingly it takes
place in the main Marvel Universe it's
just a moment that we' never really
heard of before but by tying in the the
creation of the brainwashing helmet to
the Predator's helmet now it establishes
it as being in continuity because it's
just a main part of his character at
least that's kind of all I really have
to go on but the fact remains here right
Wolverine just kind of puts together
these little bits and pieces right just
kind of goes through and just kind of
does a little bit of investigative work
in the modern era because remember the
actual fights between Wolverine and
Predator those are taking place in the
past he's recollecting all these little
things and so as a brief kind of
reprieve here in the present day he's
walking around with the Predator's
helmet because likely he's trying to
draw it back in right trying to draw his
attention for like one final
confrontation I feel like that's
important to throw out there because
we're getting towards the end of that
story so that will likely be a
significant moment as to why it is the
Predator shows up again in the first
place but what ends up going on here is
we jump back to the muramasa estate in
the past now anybody who knows anything
about Wolverine's Mythos is probably
just like oh my God yes muramasa yes man
muramasa is amazing so mamas was
considered the greatest swordsmith in
the history of Marvel Comics nobody made
better swords than this guy but the
other reason why mamasa is so important
is because one he trained Wolverine on
how to fight and two he's the creator of
the mamasa blade basically this blade
that Wolverine possesses that was
created by muramasa and a portion of
Wolverine's Soul was put into the sword
what that meant is that if the mamasa
blade even Cuts Wolverine once it shuts
off his healing factor and literally he
just becomes a regular guy it nullifies
his mutant ability he would die due to
any number of things right adamantium
poisoning the weight of the adamantium
crushing his body whatever it happened
to be right this guy could be killed in
any number of ways but as they're
training one of the cool things you kind
of get here is the desire of wolver rain
to use his claws but as muramasa says no
you need to learn to fight in the art of
the sword because if you can learn to
fight with both your sword and your
claws you could be indestructible you
could be this unbeatable guy that no one
can stand against which is an accurate
statement and in fact that's one of the
ways in which Wolverine has become so
deadly over the years and so what ends
up happening is that as these guys are
training and as these guys are talking
muramasa picks up on the fact that
something's coming and then Wolverine
realizes the same thing only for the two
of them to realize the Predator has
arrived that it's basically adapted and
as far as it's concerned it's now a
full-on knck down drag out fight it's
hunting its perfect Trophy and so now
the whole situation has evolved and
you've got wolver rain and mamasa facing
off against the Predator which we'll
find out what happens in the next video
with that being said guys we're going to
bring this to an end Cliffhangers and I
will catch you all later peace